I am only seven but I understand that it
is this fact more than any other that
makes my family different we don't go to
school our guest today was 17 when she
first entered a classroom Tara Westover
has experienced both the most
unconventional and elite ends of
education the youngest of seven children
in Mormon family with apocalyptic
beliefs she grew up sorting scrap metal
on an isolated farm in Idaho but she
went on to study at Harvard and to gain
a PhD in history from Cambridge
University in Britain educated her
memoir is the story of these two very
different worlds and it made brocco
bombers list of favorite books of the
year American politicians on both sides
have long criticized the country's
public education system Ronald Reagan
worried about a rising tide of
mediocrity charter schools were
conceived as a clinton-era remedy to
that George W Bush spoke of the soft
bigotry of low expectations the current
education secretary Betsy DeVos
champions deregulation of private
schools to increase choice for students
so as policymakers divided over how and
what young people to learn this week
we're asking what does it mean to be
educated welcome Tara thanks for having
me on the show great pleasure so tell me
about your early education I mentioned
briefly that your family had quite
strong quite fundamentalist beliefs and
that affected the way that you were
taught all not taught from the start
yeah so my my family was a bit unusual
even for my southern very small rural
farming town that I grew up in I was
youngest to seven children my dad I had
these kind of radical beliefs so his
beliefs made him opposed to a lot of the
institutions that most people just take
for granted doctors and hospitals were
out of the question we never went we
were born at home delivered by kind of
unofficial midwives and we were never
registered a lot of us for birth
certificates for example I got my birth
certificate when I was nine and then of
course we never went to school because
my dad
was concerned that it had been
infiltrated and corrupted by some kind
of hard to explain really I guess the
closest thing I could say is the
Illuminati that old conspiracy theory
that there was this nefarious
organization that had infiltrated the
government and he thought the public
school so he just wanted to keep us at
home away from all of that and will you
taught it at home you said when you were
seven there in your little clip from
your book that you realize this is
different I didn't go to schools who you
knew enough about what other children
didn't how were you taught I had I was
taught how to read being um there being
literate was very important to my family
and we had to be able to read in order
to read the Bible so I was taught to
read at a very young age and I read the
Bible in the Book of Mormon and other
religious texts but there wasn't
anything like a formal education I never
wrote an essay for my mother we never
had a lecture or an exam or anything
like that so it was it was pretty
informal and given that so how did you
respond to that time in your education I
think you write it in the book very
moving about going off and kind of I
wasn't hiding a way to write things or
to read things knowledge almost like a
secret pleasure well I you know it's
kind of funny I I didn't read that much
as a child I read a lot of religious
books because I thought I was supposed
to do that so I did do that and I kept a
journal that I I wrote in really
regularly from the time I was very young
but I lived a kind of wild American
Western life you know we had a mountain
we had a junkyard we had horses that we
broke ourselves and this was my day to
day and I was pretty happy with that I
think it first entered into my head that
I might want to go to school when I was
much older and you know I knew other
kids in my town went to school and I
knew that we were different but I think
the thing about being a child is
whatever life you have as far as you
know that's normal it's not like you
have other lives
you just let you just have the one and
so whatever world your parents build for
you feels like the world the way it
should be so I knew other kids went to
school and that we didn't but the way I
experienced that was them we were right
and they were wrong
and I would go through this whole
process of becoming educated and I put
that in kind of air quotes because I
think what it means to become educated
is a massive question but I think part
of what everyone goes through when they
go through that experience becoming
educated is figuring out what bits of
that world that was built for them in a
childhood are they going to hold on to
and what bits are they going to let go
of and how are they going to reconcile
those relationships I think education is
a is a whole process of working out who
you are from who you were and the
identity that you choose from the ones
other people give to you and when you
did decide you wanted to study and that
you would need to leave him to do that
what sort of reaction did you get my
father had pretty strong feelings that I
stay at home and become an herbalist
like my mother or become a midwife like
my mother I kind of kind of self-taught
Midwife not like here there's no she
didn't go to school get a certificate
but I it's a strange thing to explain to
me why I ended up waking up every
morning for about a year and learning
algebra studying algebra trying to teach
myself algebra so that I could take the
ACG which is a test you get gets you
into college basically and I get asked a
lot by people you know how did you have
to drive with the fortitude or the
conviction to do this and I have a
really disappointing answer for them
because I don't really know but I think
I think the closest thing to an answer I
can give you is that when I was around 8
years old my brother Tyler played me
some opera music his first time I'd ever
heard it and the second that I heard an
aria I just understood that that test
style of singing was not something that
you just knew how to do naturally you
had to go somewhere and learn that there
were people in the world somewhere in
the world that knew how to sing like
that and you had to go find them I
learned from them and I understood the
university as being that place that you
went to to go get this knowledge and so
a strange as it sounds to say I I don't
think it's a stretch to say that I
taught myself algebra because I love to
sing there's much of a lesson to be
extracted from that but if there is I
think it's that we should maybe be very
careful before we kill off any passion
and a child you don't really know where
a passion will take
we'll take someone but you know that
having no passion will take them nowhere
my love of music took me to Brigham
Young University that's where I
discovered history that's where I
discovered philosophy that would take me
to Cambridge when I was at Cambridge I
would discover language I would
eventually write this book and all of
that
I think sprang strangely enough from
just a love of song not that's nowhere
near where I ended up we might digging a
bit later to it to what we think we want
to take away from this in terms of the
broader debate about education and how
we think about reform education but I
want to just stay back a little if I
could in your what your story and your
time at Brigham Young in Utah see the
great Mormon College how did you get on
with that given that you'd come from we
were quite careful really and in sort of
describing your background because you
weren't from a background which all
Mormons would accept as being any sense
the mainstream of their faith you go to
Brigham Young which I suppose is where
he noticed ambitious Mormons go to study
how did you arrive then how did you get
along badly uh for a couple of reasons
my family weren't representative of
Mormonism at all my whole town was
Mormon and everybody went to school they
had birth certificates they went to the
doctor my family was this kind of
radical extreme version of Mormonism so
when I went to Brigham Young University
which was full of mainstream Mormons I
didn't fit in well at all for one thing
I had never been around kids my own age
I'd never gone my town they were there
were children but I'd never been to the
house they'd never been to mine I hadn't
really had friends in that traditional
sense so there was there's some serious
social skills that were rather badly
they were lacking and the other the
other thing of it was it was a spiritual
thing because I'd been raised in this
more extreme version I actually found
BYU to be incredibly licentiousness so I
was looking at these very devout pious
Mormons and just appalled by the way
they dressed what they ate the movies
they watched everything I thought that
they were these really licentiousness
eyed thing was ignorance I because I had
not been educated there were things that
separated me from my peers that was just
a knowledge of the world and one of my
first lectures I raised my hand and I
asked what the Holocaust was I had never
heard of it before
and
the other students they very much heard
that as I heard not as me denying it
actually so they heard it as
anti-semitism I didn't mean it that way
I'd never had no idea what they were
talking about but there were there were
all of these things that would just kind
of separate you from what years were
yuge
Brigham Young 2000 the January of 2005
until the middle of 2008 I guess you
know but in 2004 sorry I'm just
wondering how your own experience then
fitted with what America was going
through at the time and did you feel
very connected to the broader American
story with you now I know students would
say I hear that as Holocaust denial when
you were simply asking a question for
the basis of of not know me now the
world my world was that mountain I grew
up on and then it slowly expanded to
include that drive between Idaho and
Salt Lake City which is about three and
a half hours and no I mean New York was
a place for me that I was fake Leah
where existed because of 9/11 I knew
that New York had been hit by something
terrible but no I would say this funny
thing happened to me when I went to
London for the first time which you know
happened toward the end of my time at
the University where I was in Kings
Cross and I I had read the Harry Potter
books my grandmother had given them to
me cool yeah when I was a teenager I had
come across them and I was sitting in
Kings Cross and I looked over and I saw
the the hand cart the cart they have
there that's pushed into the wall it
used to be a bit different I think than
it is now but I saw it I looked at the
sign that said King's Cross and I
realized I was in London and I should
finally put it all together and I
realized oh not everything in the book
was made up like I had thought that
she'd made up everything I don't realize
London was a real place when I was
reading those books I don't realise
Kings Cross was a real voice yeah so
then I got I went and kind of reread
them and sort of oh these are real
things to which she's attached fiction
but I didn't know I'd never heard of
London tell me the end of your formative
years what then happens in your family
is the thing that sort of puzzled me
going through your book is you're both
extremely isolated is you describing
this very strong fuse you should
survivalism
your family preparing particular that
your fault driven by your father for the
end of the world and yet the number of
your siblings also have phd's I think
it's three out of seven in the family
which we've been remarkably high
proportion but even for a generation
we're very divided yeah there's kind of
half of us who don't have a high school
diploma you some of my siblings have in
their later years got a GED or or things
like that but yeah this incredible
division I would say between the three
of us who just took education I went all
the way and then the four of us who
didn't and I try and for that I can't
account for it I caution people against
trying to extrapolate Social Policy from
it because you could say well let's
deprive everyone event of an education
because then roughly you know three out
of four three out of seven will will
really overcompensate and once they get
a hold of it they'll be absolutely crazy
for it and that is what happened with us
but I think my brother's if you met them
they're special people and they are they
they were just academically minded they
were scientists they just were from the
time were very young and yes they fought
their way out of out of the ignorant
that they've been raised with and the
the lack of education but I think it was
hard for them and I wouldn't say just
because they were able to do it that it
would be a reasonable thing to say to
everybody oh let's deprive everyone of
education and I hope it works out well
policy from that point of view but tell
me a bit about what you think having
such an unorthodox upbringing did
prepare you for I mean are there things
that you can learn perhaps from that
more independent way of approaching
passions and discovery then you've seen
since as you've been in more formal
education would you be able to impart I
think there are things that I'm
comfortable saying even with my
reluctance to extrapolate from a small
sample size but I guess I would say one
of the things that struck me from moving
out of the way I was raised into a more
mainstream society and therefore a more
mainstream way of thinking about
education is the degree to which educate
has become standardized and
institutionalized and it seems if is
really about discovery it's about
learning and that gets lost I think
pretty quickly when when we lose that
distinction between an education and a
school for example I really don't think
that the same thing I think the school
is just the mechanism that we use to try
to impart an education but but it's an
institution and because it's an
institution it it's subject to all the
flaws and foibles of any human
institution and there's something
terribly passive I would say about the
way that education seems to be conceived
of in the mainstream I I kind of go back
to John Dewey on this that great
education reformer he said that there
are two components to an education
there's the individual and social or
what the individual brings to their
education and what society brings to
that education and he says that you have
to be in balance the way I see it I
think my parents had a way overemphasize
the individual they took that way too
far but sometimes I look at the
mainstream system and I think I think we
might have taken the other one a bit far
and probably what we need to do is find
that middle ground I happen to think
that there is space even in an
institutionalized social education for
individual choice for people to have
meaningful to make meaningful decisions
about progressive theorists of Education
always claimed by the progressive
tendency but it sounds like you wouldn't
necessarily attach yourself to something
like the common core argument in America
where on the whole and there are
exceptions in states with it sort of
different leanings but progressives to
tend to think that Common Core was quite
a good idea and perhaps those as you go
to the right feel that it undermines
states right so now ultimately
individual rights to choose I you know I
I I've looked a little bit into common
core common core seems to be a set of
standards I don't actually have too much
of a problem with the idea that there's
core information that we need to impart
to people but you already deciding then
what is literally cool to a curriculum
and what is seen is I don't have a
problem saying here are the here
some things that you can't do without
but I feel like what you really need is
you also need space for people to make
meaningful choices about what they learn
and in order for that to work the
reality is you need extremely high
quality teachers you need to have
teachers that you can trust in the
classroom otherwise you do have to
standardize absolutely everything but I
tend to think it's just a principle of
human nature that you people need to
feel like they have control over their
lives anyone who has a two-year-old
knows it's just a it's just a fact of
life you can tell them all right you
have to take a nap or you have to clean
your room and I that's not a real choice
they have to do one of two things
neither of which they actually want to
do but just giving them that option that
illusion of control they will be happier
than if you just see all right time to
take a nap and I think it's the small
level choices do you want to read
Dickens do you want to read Austen that
that that idea that your education
actually belongs to you in a meaningful
way and you've chosen to read this text
and not that one I think it's incredibly
important and I think you can have core
standards and say yes everyone needs to
learn how to divide and everyone needs
to learn and still leave space in your
curriculum for people to make meaningful
choices about what goes into their heads
and if you want to say your education
and mean it in anyway you have to give
them those choices you have a PhD in
intellectual history and I wonder if
there's a time and will allow you any
number of centuries you've got free
range here and we're going to put
practicality to one side when there's an
approach to education a way of looking
at education carrying it out even if
it's for small groups or in an
experimental way that would appeal to
you funny enough even though I know I
have a PhD in history
I think I'll bring us right back to the
present my brother Tyler has a really
interesting system with his own children
they homeschool their children and we
were homeschooled in this way that was
extremely lacs
and there was almost no actual education
taking place formal education anyway and
my brother Tyler has homeschooled his
kids and in general I would say before I
saw Tyler home school his kid that was
completely against it had this difficult
experience I arrived at college not
knowing anything and I'm against home
school and it was very straightforward
and I've watched him actually homeschool
his children and I've watched how
the kids can get completely obsessed
with icebergs or they can get obsessed
with glaciers and that natural curiosity
they will just take them off for a week
two weeks however long their their
interest lasts they just go with it I
mean I think it can be a really
wonderful thing especially for younger
children my concern with the education
system we have is that so many people's
experience of Education for the first
five or ten years of their life seems to
be sitting quietly in a room while
someone tells them something they don't
want to know and so by the time they
even get to their to their education
they've already have a very
institutionalized passive slightly jaded
view of it and that seems I think if you
look at some of the best performing
education systems on our own time people
think the Scandinavian examples pretty
seriously they actually tend to start a
bit older and they don't force the kids
I think that that question of what a
child thinks an education is and what
are the experiences that we're giving
them that tell them is this work or is
this pleasure I think it's an incredibly
important thing my brothers kids what
I'm really struck with when I when I
interact with them is that they do not
understand that school is work they
don't see it as different from play in
general there occasionally forced to do
math that they don't want to do and they
understand that that they think that's
work most of them but yeah there's some
stuff it's got to happen but in general
they have an incredible tolerance for
learning things because it's never been
made explicit to them this is supposed
to be fun against home school I kind of
did and I saw my brother and a lot of
people from from a position at the
moment where it's become a bit of a
political hot potato in the u.s. hasn't
it yeah I I do think we need to rethink
the way that we conceive of learning we
have this incredibly institutionalized
behemoth system I don't know what the UK
is like as well as I know the US example
but the teachers I talked to you know
someone from my hometown I spoke to
recently who is the valedictorian of her
graduating class went into teaching and
I spoke to her a few years ago she said
this is the last year I can do this it's
not a life they don't pay me well enough
the hours I worker and
I can't look after myself and do this
job and she again she was valedictorian
of her high school she could have taken
a much higher job she took that job
because she loved it and found that it
was just completely untenable with the
with the wages and it seems insane to me
that as a society we would say so loudly
and so often education is the most
important thing this is what we value
and we refuse to pay for it serve as it
you were you're an opera of education
spending any other prescriptions I
suppose I had my three prescriptions I
would say we should think seriously
about what we indoctrinate children to
think in education is at the earlier
years and whether they think it's
miserable or not if they hate it we
should stop doing it that way because it
shouldn't be introduced to them as work
the second thing is as much we need our
core things everyone needs to know how
to add and subtract and do those things
but in as much as we can introduce
choice I think we ought to do that and I
think the quality of teachers you have
to have the best teachers you can
possibly get and the reality is if
you're going to get the best teachers
you're going to need to make that a life
for those people it can't be it cannot
be that you're not paying them and it
cannot be that you're not respecting
them and it cannot be that they're
teaching so many classes a day that
they're pulling their hair out it has to
be it has to be an industry that will
attract high quality people I wondered
when you move to Cambridge and by the
stage you have postgraduate you were
coming in at the end of the system but
you're coming into the top end of what
is Britain's equivalent of the Ivy
League whether this sort of I this
either strangeness that you'd brought to
your first college experience at Brigham
Young whether that came back to you as
you went in to to Cambridge in the
thinking to Trinity College in one of
the grandest of the Cambridge colleges
how did it strike you I think my my jump
from where I grew up to BYU was by far
the most difficult and just that initial
transition for my immediate family to
any university was strange I've never
written an essay never take any time I
had no idea what was going on
Cambridge though was a little bit yeah
at that quality of stepping through the
glass just not really understanding
what was happening as a foreign country
and Cambridge looks it doesn't even look
like a real place if you're from the
United States it's just range so this
architecture could actually exist so
Cambridge was an incredibly strange
thing I think a bridge residents feel
free to get in touch at any time I think
it was I was lucky in a way though cuz I
think all of the things that are
difficult about Cambridge if you come
from an unorthodox background a
lower-class background or whatever it is
I think I kind of got a I got to evade
all of those almost because I was
American and so a lot of my friends that
I've known at Cambridge who came from
from a working-class background who
struggled more and they've said things
to me like well the second I opened my
mouth I feel like people know I don't
belong here and I didn't have that
there's actually not a radical
survivalist accent so I had when I
arrived at BYU I had a particular
vernacular that not a lot of verbs
subject agreement going on in the way
that I I i spoke but i caught on to that
pretty quickly and worked it out and
stopped i didn't have an accent there's
not an accent where people can say oh
you were raised by radicals uh so in a
way I feel like I was kind of absolved
of the whole thing people don't know
what to make of you when you're from
abroad they just kind of they assume
they have no idea and you all start from
a clean slate what relationship then
remained for you with your family and
with your background is such a specific
experience and it's also your family
it's a big family
a loving family but in the end something
that you felt was misguided it was a
loving family and my family you know
part of the book is about estrangement
and it's about difficult choices you
have to make I had an older brother who
from the time I was young had been
violent towards me violent towards
others and it was something my family
was just not able to deal with and the
the reality was as I grew older as I
became again air quotes educated I mean
that in the broadest sense the classes
you take all the ways you going to think
for yourself and make decisions for
yourself the more that I changed the
harder it was for me to go back and
accept that situation and it became
apparent during toward the end of my
time at Cambridge I wasn't gonna be able
to continue living like that my parents
were not going to be able to change and
we could love each other value the
history that we had together but there
wasn't a way forward I either had to
stay the same and accept the violence of
that relationship or I could change and
I would have to go and that is what I
chose to do and so the book does have
some heavy themes in it about what are
the obligations that you are your family
versus the obligations that you already
yourselves did in touch with me I'm
estranged from half my family and I'm
close with the other half and then my
aunts and uncles on my mother's side I'm
very close with but I'm strange from
half so the the question of Education
becomes one of again I hope not so much
classrooms and getting uh certificates
you can make a better living I really
dislike the idea of reducing education
to job training my life turned out very
differently because the education I was
given I made very different choices with
regards to my family my relationship
with my brother and I I think a lot of
that was my education and you could have
taught me how to code or taught me how
to use Excel and made me more employable
but it just wouldn't have had that that
that same effect there's a bit of a wave
of books about the urban-rural divide in
America at the moment a lot of writing
about hillbilly elegy by JD Vance we've
covered similar themes on this show and
also when we've been traveling in the
u.s. when you're writing your book
you're going to be read a lot by the
urban elites all those who perhaps you
are more comfortably situated or more
curious yeah how do you sort of worry
how much do you worry that it it's a bit
of voyeurism for the world to do looking
at the lives of the poor what did we
learn from it
I don't take the book as a sociological
that's very different from hillbilly
elegy and he meant his story to be
representative of you know read this if
you want to understand these people I
don't say that my family is not
representative of Idaho even as I said
there they were outliers even for our
small town so I don't say Oh read my
book if you want to understand these
this sociological phenomenon because all
Idahoans don't go to the doctor and they
keep their kids out of school they they
don't do either of those things so I I
think of it more as a family story and a
story about what education is
it means to become educated what it
means to change how you navigate
relationships with people who find it
difficult to allow you to change I think
of it more as a personal story and my
story might be kind of on the extreme
side of things but I actually think it's
a universal experience to some degree or
another every person has to decide what
it means to grow up and how much they're
going to define themselves in connection
to their family and how much in Contra
distinction do their family everybody
has to make that struggle and I do think
that's part of what education means in
that broad sense not of classrooms and
textbooks but of all the different
perspectives that you could access to
and the effort that you make to try to
create your own mind and your own ideas
dari Westover thank you very much for
joining us thanks for having me